c'était un débat de bonne tenue où on a
pu aborder un grand nombre de sujets
évidemment sans toujours avec un peu de
frustration parce que on aurait aimé
développer l'intégralité de son projet
mais c'est pas possible en 2h30 voilà il
faut l'admettre en fait pendant 1h15 ça
n'est pas possible mais voilà moi j'ai
trouvé que le débat c'était déroulé
rapidement je sais pas si des les gens
qui ont regardé ont eu le même sentiment
je le souhaite je l'espère plus rapide
plus structuré oui plus
calme en effet de gagner cette fois face
à Emmanuel Macron
qui a gagné
je parle de me lancer là-dedans ça
m'intéresse assez peu mais le débat
s'est déroulé
encore une fois sereinement correctement
et c'est ce qui est le plus important
parce que c'est ce que je crois
attendent les Français
vous savez quand vous ferez un débat à
la présidentielle pour le second tour on
en parlera évidemment on est on est
heureux quand on a pu exposer
quasiment l'intégralité son projet
évidemment j'aurais aimé par les plus
des aidants des de l'outre-mer de des
TPEPME bien sûr mais voilà c'est la
règle du jeu il faut l'accepter
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé de la taxe sur le
pré russe Madame Le Pen j'ai mis
attendais très objectivement je pense
que ça démontre aussi que il y a assez
peu de d'attaques qui portent sur le
fond en fait du projet moi j'ai entendu
depuis 10 jours beaucoup de dénaturation
de mon projet enfin j'ai entendu parler
de choses je ne reconnaissais pas ce que
je propose aux Français
beaucoup d'outrans
parfois même des insultes après tout je
peux vous dire ce soir je suis contente
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas suivi la
technique de campagne de ses équipes qui
ne se grandissent pas en faisant ce
genre de choses parce que une
présidentielle c'est projet contre
projet c'est pas projet qu'on trouve
trans projet contre un Sud projet contre
agressivité projet contre brutalité
c'est pas ça un second tour et c'est pas
ce que tu en es français il a quand même
[Musique]